[Music]
in 1935
albert einstein was famously disturbed
by an idea in quantum physics
when two particles are quantum entangled
they can instantaneously interact across
vast distances einstein found this
phenomenon
spooky
just the next year alan turing
identified a problem computers would
never be able to solve
computers usually operate based on
inputs and outputs
but sometimes they can get stuck in
infinite loops
touring proved there's no way to tell
when this will happen and he called it
the halting problem
today we recognize it in the spinning
wheel of death
in the 1930s quantum entanglement and
the halting problems seem to have
nothing to do with each other
but this year they combined in a
landmark proof that set off a cascade of
solutions to open problems in computer
science
physics and mathematics
[Music]
this is henry yuen he's one of five
co-authors of the proof you know what
this paper is about
it's in computational complexity theory
which is like a branch
of theoretical computer science and it
talks about the computational
power of a model of what's called
interactive proofs
an interactive proof is a kind of
logical interrogation method that models
computation as the exchange of messages
between two parties
approver and a verifier to understand
how this works
imagine the verifier is a police officer
interrogating two subjects
the provers you can't go out and confirm
every single detail of the suspect's
stories
but by asking the right questions and
pitting your subjects against each other
you can catch them in a lie or develop
confidence that the facts check out
the policemen will place these two
suspects in different rooms
but it just so happens that these
suspects also can share quantum
entanglement to coordinate their
responses
in some uh spooky quantum mechanical
fashion the policeman's job is to
to try to figure out what the truth
really is
the main result of this paper is that
even though
the these suspects might share
quantum entanglement the policemen can
actually interrogate them in such a way
that
the policemen can figure out the truth
of
any mathematical statement corresponding
to an enormously
complicated range of questions this
means that in theory a super powerful
quantum computer could verify answers to
even unsolvable
problems like touring's halting problem
it involves all these really beautiful
pieces
from different areas things from
computer science
things from mathematics and physics that
you know
before we didn't think were that related
to each other and yet they are
i think it points to something much more
interesting i don't know what but
you know there's a feeling that there's
something more to you know there's like
a whole new
new world to discover
this is john horton conway his infamous
knot problem eluded mathematicians for
half a century
the question asked whether the conway
knot was actually a slice of a higher
dimensional knot
a property called sliceness this
question proved answerable for thousands
of similar knots
but conway's resisted every attempt to
untangle it
lisa picharillo was a graduate student
when she first heard about the conway
knot
well i just thought it was completely
ridiculous that we didn't know whether
this knot was
slice or not we have a lot of tools for
doing this sort of thing so i didn't
understand like why for some 11 crossing
knot this should be so difficult
i think the next day which was a sunday
i just started trying to run the
approach for fun and i worked on it a
bit in the evenings just to try to see
like
what's supposed to be so part about this
problem
and then the following week i had a
meeting with cameron gordon a
senior topologist in in my department um
about something else and i mentioned it
to him there he was like
oh really you showed the conway nuts nut
slice like
show me um and then i started to put it
up
um and he started asking kind of
detailed questions and then
at some point he got he got very excited
picturillo's proof was published in the
annals of mathematics
it was it was quite surprising to me i
mean it's just one not
in general when mathematicians prove
things we
we like to prove really broad general
statements all objects like this have
some property and i proved like
one knot has a thing i don't care about
knots
um so i do care about three and
four dimensional spaces though um and
it turns out that when you want to study
three and four dimensional spaces you
find yourself studying doubts anyway
mathematics can sometimes seem like a
jumbled mosaic
major areas of study have never been
fully written down
and doing so would have required using
thousands of other definitions that
don't yet exist
now imagine you had a library of
alexandria that contained the entire
history and the sum total of
mathematical knowledge
with everything catalogued you could
program an ai to verify increasingly
complex proofs
and one day hopefully come up with new
ones on its own
at imperial college london kevin buzzard
is in the process of digitizing math
he's teaching it to a software called
lean which draws upon an ever-growing
library of proofs
and theorems i decided that this
software was
very interesting about three years ago
and have since made a huge amount of
noise about it
we took some very very modern
mathematics
and just show you know we taught it to
lead and lean could handle it and
basically it was at that point that i
realized it should be able to do
anything
really lean has a big maths library 450
000 lines of code long the library just
grows all the time every day you know
10 more 10 more pull requests get added
to this library the growth is
immense it's just slowly eating
mathematics
computers speak a certain language so
there's a fast
moving language which you have to learn
and then once you've done that you just
explain the mathematics but in that
language and the big problem is that
in maths departments across the world
we're teaching people the mathematical
ideas
but nobody's teaching them the language
that these computers speak
mathematics is not quite what it's sold
i mean we tell the undergraduates that
mathematics is this completely
rigorous you know theory built from the
axioms
and in practice that's not how
mathematics is done
computers are quite picky because they
do want
they do want to know what's going on so
one challenge we have faced
is that people are slightly imprecise
and computers don't buy it
before you can teach something to the
computer
you do need to understand it perfectly
the act of
engaging with the details can sometimes
clarify the situation you end up with a
proof which is slightly messy
and then you try and type it into a
computer and at the end of it you end up
with a with a slicker argument
one of the goals is that we want to see
an entire undergraduate curriculum in it
and you know give us another couple of
years and and then we will be able to
honestly say
you know that it's as smart as an
undergraduate in some sense
you